how do you juggle your time if you're
like most entrepreneurs you're working
crazy hours putting everything you got
into your business running every
position in your business from the CEO
down to the janitor and if you really
want to have breakthroughs then you have
to make sure you're spending your time
wisely because that's the biggest asset
that's going into your company and if
you spend too much time on the wrong
project it could sink your business so
got a question from an entrepreneur love
more who wrote in to say how do you
juggle your time and the running of your
business empire so I could go on for a
long time talking about time management
all the different stuff that I've done
but a few highlights that may help guide
your thinking if you think about how
you're going to spend your time the
first thing you need to think about is
eliminating the things that you don't
need to do too many of us are running
programs and projects and initiatives
that we do not need to do they are not
really adding much to our business you
could eliminate a lot of the stuff on
your plate right now and it would have
zero impact on your bottom line the next
thing is look at what you can automate I
hate doing the same thing over and over
and over and over again first of all
you're likely to make mistakes second of
all it's really boring and third of all
it's not a good use of your time if
anything can be automated things should
find ways to do it and look at software
that can help you or create your own
software or web tools to help you do it
a great example is accounting right if
you're doing accounting and you're using
Excel you're you know have your receipts
in a shoebox just get an account in
software package it's so much faster it
saves you so much time I just download
my statements pop it into my counter
software remembers everything and spits
out the statement and it takes for like
20 minutes a quarter to do my account
super simple because most of it is
automated I have a programmer on staff
and he will help take a lot of the
things that I hate doing repeatedly you
have to do something two or three times
then I try to find a way to automate it
because I'm going to start making
mistakes I get bored and there's better
use
my time the third thing to think about
is delegation so we've eliminated all
the stuff we shouldn't be doing we've
automated as much as possible then look
at what's left on your plate so these
are mission critical things things are
really helping grow your business you
don't have to do everything yourself you
got to think about what are you best at
in the world and how can you delegate
the other things away to other people
people usually start delegating admin
stuff right nobody likes to an admin
stuff entrepreneurs hate doing admin
work we like the big picture we like the
visionary stuff we like the exciting
projects it's never the admitted me so I
could spend that hour doing something
else right you don't have to hire a
full-time person straight off the bat
but doing those things quickly frees up
your time to focus on the higher
priority projects a few more tips that
will help you I've got a lot to say on
this stuff so if you want more detail
anything particular let me know because
I've created a whole sections of
worksheets on this and you can go
through to help figure this out for you
better so some more ideas one I don't
answer my phone my phone number is not
on my business card and if somebody
calls in I don't pick it up unless it's
my family because they know my number
most people don't even know my number
when the phone rings in my office is a
surprise like who's calling because
phone calls are such a waste of time
unscheduled phone calls I do a lot of
business by the phone but I'm always
calling out the people at set times
because when somebody calls you up
you're in the middle of working on
something what happens the answer the
phone may even take five minutes you put
down the phone you figure out what you
were doing it takes you half an hour
just to get back in the flow of where
you were before unscheduled phone calls
are other people's agenda for your time
and you can't let them take up your time
okay next e-mails can be the same thing
right the email comes in if you check
every minute it comes in ding ding the
light goes off you stop working on what
you're doing to check your email huge
productivity suck either check your
email at a designated time spend an hour
a day doing email and then let it go or
sort it at least you have really
important people we
we'll check frequently and everybody
else can wait until the next day next
try to build a no crisis business I hate
working with clients who are I don't
want to say demanding but always in a
state of emergency like we need this
right now we need this right now so
you're constantly just reacting and
putting out fires instead of proactively
growing and building your business so I
work with clients who respect my process
and who I can deliver great results to
if they follow the process I'm just
working on a deal with a huge company in
the US and then kind of under NDA so I
can't say anything with the name but
they wanted me to sign a contract like
sure I'll signed the contract no problem
send me send me the contract up but they
wouldn't do it electronically they FedEx
it to me and wanted me to then FedEx it
back to them one page to be fed ex that
I could scan in easily send it off and
it took me a long time they took me like
two weeks to do it because i never could
go down the street to my fedex office to
do it because i was so busy doing other
stuff it wasn't important enough for me
to go and spend that time doing this
could be a big contract for me and so
today i actually made it to the office
send it out and just as I was I was
finishing the guy emailed me and said
hey what's happening with the contract
that we still on and I robot to say I
just sent it out today here's a tracking
number if you sent this electronically
it would have been done the next day I
love econ tracks and a little happy face
and sand and I said okay okay well know
that for next time and so it's training
people to respect your time and your
process because if the companies that I
work with always made me do that stuff I
just be running around with my head cut
off never actually being able to do
anything to grow my business so those
are a few tips for you I still got a ton
the same time management but I'm you
know conscious of your your time
watching YouTube video if you liked the
video you want to see more please give
it a thumbs up below and if you have
further questions you want going to dive
deeper on any of these topics or you
have a different question for your
business leave
below in the comments and I'll
absolutely create a video response for
you thank you so much and I'll see you
soon